signori siamo arrivati al finale di the
forest sulla seconda parte questo è
proprio il finale definitivo è un gioco
della madonna e sono orgoglioso di
averlo portato sul mio canale
insieme a questi pazzi maniaci dei miei
amici buona visione
salve girati potenza di strano aspettavo
al via salmi senta lei mi dica un ottimo
questa biscaretti posiziona l'intervista
ho fatto con montemagno cosa ne pensa
lei dell'articolo 13 niente perché
c'erano solo favorevole e ci crediamo
abbiamo c'è un boss selection boss morto
qua si sbuca davanti lo attende
ma visto come visto non ha visto aspetta
aspetta possiamo così incazzato perché
non credo ne abbia non mi ha visto
quindi dobbiamo ancora la vittoria via
non ci passa la porta ciccione scherzato
aspettati una molotov e che male ti sei
fatto pietro occhio dell'ideale molotov
è bravo non ci passa alla porta tirate
molotov che lui sia morto è morto morto
lo voi ci faccio un armatura ora come ha
fatto a morire a lei ma lei un usato la
motosega
sì ora non riusciamo a passare perché si
passa mi si passa ricerca ora facciamo
al giro sporco demonio è riuscita a
passare sotto poi c'è stata un altro
boss morto
altra gente morta qua c'è qua è successo
qualcosa di strano ma che vorrei fare
una battuta ma non posso farla è una
cosa che è esatto roba camicia che non
hai capito ma tanto centrica faccio
youtube a ciccio doveva raccontarci una
storia
allora ragazzi è vero
solo che magari sono ricoperto di sangue
come faccio a lavarmi allora sembrava è
uguale alle porte che abbiamo aperto
durante le ferie o se sono ancora ma non
mi facoltà riga si può attivare sto coso
ecco quali sono io
bravo quando si può aprire mi sa equa
coperto scoprendo facendo c'è mio figlio
dentro è morto dice controlliamo è morto
[Musica]
è morto mio figlio perché hanno
ammazzato il figlio pezzi di culo
ma non ci credo che ci assorbe den ding
the forest perché porta fine ma dai
orribile scusate ma io ho bambini ma non
voi non ce l'avete no sul letto la butta
lì ma no sto male alla messa del momento
sul cavo che brutta storia mi ha messo
il mondo amici ma dai non ci credo agli
specchi sto collegandosi cosi come se
possono potesse salvarlo da un momento
all'altra anni posso cosa posso salvare
forse aspetta new sample required suol
dire non è che uno di noi l'eventuale
ciccio rai plc ciò fa il fisico grazie
ai mezzi si è sacrificato subito la
ciccia è stato bello conoscerti brave
ragazze non posso entrare però non so
perché non trova un nuovo sacrificio
ok ragazzi alla prima di andare in giro
magari riusciamo a trovare qualche volta
per 6 madonna che figata su un campo da
basket rega enorme questo posto
significa che c'è un boss fight secondo
me e mia mamma mi non ci dovrebbe essere
il boss non è che compaiono tipo
superman in vetro il pavimento è assurdo
sarebbe un peccato qualcuno lo facesse
nora che non penso sia un boss fight tre
o quattro cigo di villa quante guarda
qualora guarda cosa sono io qua cielo se
farle esplodere
sicuramente c'è il boss c'è la bambina
della bambina a me gabola eccola
sacrificio per mio figlio che però mi sa
che l'aspetta pietro mi sa che mi facci
lontanissimo tipo mi sa che non è fra
cui una bambina
male visto che qui coperta di sangue cia
la bocca sporca di sangue e che appena
guardato in faccia e mi sta guardando
malissimo tesoro cosa è successo quella
torero plano e caduto ecco visto hai
visto e sei stata tu arrestato regista
scusando per aver buttato giù un
aeroplano messo a 3 secondo me i ragazzi
sta bambina ha dei problemi dei problemi
la bambina laga quando ok più di
scappare loro io vorrei scappare ma il
mio personaggio inchiodato per terra
ragazzi però è tutto vostro
ma voi madonna chi botte tira occhi
occhio non spiegate le bombe porca vacca
dovresti portarla verso un punto e io
facevo fatica a che cosa si aspetta che
prova a colpirla chi ha scioccato ma
vieni la via la via emilia con la presa
ma perché scia con tom mentre spetta
aspetto anche
oddio ragazzi sta che mi sta
intercettando è stato anche stando a me
quindi il colpite la fate qualcosa se
non con le molotov non so proprio come
colpirla vado con lascia tutti insieme
lasciamo la diversità non pensavo non lo
facciamo mai si pronuncia bestia di
satana brucia è morta davvero fi preso
la bambina l'ha presa da presa ci
giovanni la ciccia aias ed efficiente
aia porco de mori bambina morta sfilati
nel coso
speriamo di serate ha lasciato una roba
per terra o l'altra sera vai vai c'è un
altro porta nuova dio ti porta di
oblivion ragazzi però e odio questo allo
stomaco si non promette benissimo però
vabbè scheletri sono pregavano che ci
sono delle cose
attaccate al muro ma noi dobbiamo
scendere no ma non è che io ti
conosciamo ma non penso proprio
ci sarebbe un uscita dove poi arrivare
direttamente ad un finale c'è una
parcella ci siamo ricollegati
laboratorio riga la gara c'è un po di
casino qua pulite voi chi non
organizzare più quelle feste da dove
stiamo andando
l'ascensore detto trascendendo non si
promessa se non lo so rica stava salendo
bagna siamo sulla montagna ragala quanto
sincera questa roba sulla montagna e chi
l'aveva mai vista mai andati
effettivamente vai avanti
mica quanto in alto fighissimo
ora che non superò in uno scalino c'è
una scrivania fermi schiaccia il tasto
c'è un aereo c'è un aereo thomas ci sei
tu anni 4 kevin e sally ci piacciono
tanto i quali prestito con firme presso
presso ge energy non ce l'ha fatta per
far saper far cadere un aereo ma non
penso proprio che aveva prendiamo che ti
vai parenti tutti
vai premi ok ma chicca cioè la cinematic
sì sì vedete anche voi come vedo io la
vedo in questa volta si fosse tipo loop
infinito aerei liceo etici riscontrare
un altro si incassa perché gli rubi il
tiglio e continua all'infinito sta cosa
ma spero di no te che cazzo di avere
sassi e bombe e può essere non è caduto
niente dai testi o mio dio mio e ho
molte persone no no spero risalto esatto
ci sta potrebbe essere un finale un anno
più tardi cosa mio figlio ce nostro
figlio che ha dei tic strani a ci hanno
salvati ci hanno salvati ma ora lascia
mio figlio veramente dei tic orribili
[Musica]
abbiamo fatto un libro euro youtuber
erika blanc ha ci ha portato un troppo
uefa la dimostrazione di come si taglia
la legna o la sede tu che sei indigeno
ne faccio vedere come si taglia invece
tagliato
ecco insomma al synth omicida
macché
no succede nomadi spunterà di boxe dal
figlio oddio no così successo sì sì no
no one's aggiungiamo scheda nel sociale
quindi cosa è successo
cioè tu sei lì modo figlio ha problemi
mara che dovete commenta mi mille
all'ora fino a nitra di patata ciarda
basta uno sguardo qui a ci vediamo come
siamo noi cioè i notai ero tipo
messicano è questo il figlio cercando di
trovare l'isola sto male
[Musica]
ancora di spasmi
no
latte non è proprio un posto sto ragazzo
[Musica]
e spider man
com'è non va
beh non abbassa non ho capito
ok va bene è stato è stato figo cioè po
strano ragazzi vi ringrazio per avermi
accompagnato in questo finale di un
gioco che ho portato da una vita non ho
mai finito
siete proprio belli niente ragazzi voi
nei commenti mi dovete spiegare le cose
perché non ho capito ma penso nessuno di
noi però se mi spiegate sarebbe meglio
però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi come se
le piace non mi piace anche per i social
corrida dove si sia passato anche dai
canali dei ragazzi fanno bene iscrizione
e noi come al solito
[Musica]